you've been playing video games I got
modern warfare call of duty and it's fun
it's definitely fun but it's different
it's a lot different I feel like than
when I was young
these give the video games now you can't
really lose every time you get a little
they got a checkpoint they call it you
check oh you got the checkpoint whenever
you start back again you start right
here buckaroo good luck good luck young
buck you're gonna be you're gonna do
great out there then when I was young I
remember you had to look if you whedon
it like you had a couple of lives and if
you lost them all guess what you had to
start over at the beginning of the game
and it was insane I remember if you got
to the point where you gonna fight the
bad guy remember you're gonna fight
Bowser dude I would pause the game dude
I would take a break you know I get my I
get my brother dude doing massage doing
massage my hands I be putting chalk on
my hands I'll be doing cleaning jerks in
the yard I would get ready if you were
about to fight Bowser I would get a rest
for two days just leave it leave the
screen on I would be there was no steve
it-- grandma she's my good-luck charm
invite her over grandma would drive down
from illinois' if I'm fighting Bowser
you had to prepare this was it this was
the big showdown you weren't gonna get a
million chances at it remember you would
do everything you you you know you'd
have maybe your dad would even come back
and seen you in years he shows up to
help you [ __ ] to help you just to watch
you fight him and he's in disguised
because you don't want your mom trying
to get any of the money he owes and then
he leaves you lose and he's gone
but you know but there's rumors that it
was him it was just a different time and
if you were at the if you were fighting
the champ the Bowser and now it's like
you're at the end they got a movie in
between and make you feel comfortable
you can restart a million times at the
end you can't lose you can't really lose
but it was different back then you had
you remember sometimes you'd have to put
something in the machine the machine
broke after a while it broken you had to
put something there to hold the game in
place or you had to have your sister sit
there and hold the game remember that
hold the game she like I'm not holding
the game you'd am holding the game or
you ain't eating and she would hold the
game but then she would get nervous or
something she would sneeze and move both
her hands to cover her mouth because she
had manners and she and she and she and
she [ __ ] the game up and everybody
would be pissed and you wouldn't forget
it even at Christmas times you wouldn't
get her nothing and you ain't cuz you
couldn't forget that
but yeah you had look it took you a day
to get to Bowser and by God you would
train you would eat healthy you would
have all your Brussels spouts just
getting ready pause the game upstairs
you're fighting you're ready different
but you have been playing modern warfare
call of duty a little bit I don't have a
I guess I have a screen name but I don't
know how to put it out there yet out
into the ether did you enjoy that clip
well you really would have enjoyed it if
he was watching on a TCL TV TCL is
America's fastest growing TV brand it's
so fast it's the Carl Lewis of
television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its fifth anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
follow TCL at TCL underscore USA on
Twitter and Instagram for more details
for more information about TCL visit TCL
usa.com
that's TCL usa.com